car ces investigations jean michel maire
ici présents a répondu aux questions de
l'interview sans filtre de télé loisirs
avec laurent argelier qui est très bon
d'ailleurs il a fait pas mal de
confidences
il a notamment parlé de son salaire il a
révélé avoir été augmentés alors je vais
vous dire la vérité juste après et
j'étais pas au courant de tout ce que
vous venez bien non et pourtant c'est
vrai ah non je ne savais pas alors
vraiment je m'entends nous l'apprenons
mais je pense que vous avez un problème
est ce que on va revoir et les autres
ici présents sont logés à la même
enseigne
donc si j'ai dit ces mots jean-michel ça
me fait très plaisir mais vous méritiez
votre augmentation c'est sûr parce que
vous avez des excédents d'essence et
l'année dernière mais c'est bien je sais
pas comment c'est j'ai peut-être des
conneries je me suis je les adore ce mec
regarde mieux séparer 600 euros net brut
route alors au fil des années est ce que
ton caché à augmenter oui il augmenter
mais on a une très bonne augmentation
est dernière de 20% mataiea un peu les
départs quand thierry moreau est parti
quand il l'aura est parti serry s'est
dit j'espère qu'ils n'ont pas tous me
faire le coup et du coup il m'a dit jean
jé tu veux pas partir sans annoncer
aucune raison de partir j'ai rien
d'autre en plus je me plais et aulas et
puis du coup mais d'une façon j'ai été
augmenté tu bosse bien et sera donc il
va augmenter aux gens comme raison pas
sur l'asie de ma mère je ne lui ai
jamais dit ça c'est un peu une sorte de
la bouche c'est pire des cas j'aurais
webazia si toi qu'est ce tu me casses
les yeux tu mens pas mais bon c'est une
boulette singh lot
[Rires]